pressure cooker draft a friday tradition
here on pft live
looks like there's no trivia question so
because you're working on a friday
because i know how difficult that is for
you generally
i will give you the first pick thank you
friend you are so
nice i really appreciate that it's a
good one i mean this is uh
because you can hit pressure in a lot of
different angles here i think the
obvious one i get to go with is the
quarterback of chicago mitchell trubisky
yes i mean everybody's going to be
looking at him to see how he plays what
did he do
to win the job from nick foles who's a
super bowl mvp and they traded for and
i think we all expect her at least i did
i think you expected it with me for him
to be the starting quarterback
and then we know the lions defense stunk
last year
so you also add that and you think oh
they they should be able to move the
ball and do some things on the offensive
side of the ball so mitchell trubisky to
me is probably the guy that jumps out
more than anyone
yeah i think you're right because he's
got the most to lose his job and will he
be looking over his shoulder will he be
getting nervous about
a mistake here a mistake there a bad
read here an interception there a bad
throw whatever
and at some point whether it's this week
next week or the week after is he laying
the foundation to eventually be replaced
by nick foles the guy they
spent a lot of money on and gave up a
draft pick to get in the offseason so i
agree with you on that one
for me though it's a guy who hasn't
played football in 52 weeks because the
season started a week later than it
would have because labor day was as late
as it could have been we should be
getting ready for week two this weekend
and last year when we went into week two
it was seahawks at steelers and it was
ben roethlisberger's elbow
going and he was gone for the rest of
the year there is pressure on him
not job pressure he's not getting
benched for mason rudolph for josh dobbs
but to the extent that ben is coming
back
with a very high bar and he has said
he intends to win lombardi's with an
s he wants multiple championships he's
got two in his career he wants more than
one over whatever's left in it well the
pressure's on
ben to deliver on the
expectations that i think most football
people who pay close attention have
casual fan may think uh
the the people in the media who follow
it closely look at the steelers this
year and say this team
should be good and it's on ben
roethlisberger and it's not just
will he get back to being able to
perform like he did after 52 weeks of
not doing it
but was that elbow the first body part
yeah in a chain reaction of guy who's
closing in on 40 who's had the crap
kicked out of him
over the course of his career yeah i i
hope not you know i hope not because i
want to see big ben play some football i
do
i love watching him play i love the way
he hangs in there and throws the ball
down
the field and so aggressive and they
just got so many studs on their football
team especially
on the defense where you know i think
you and i look at it and we just go man
just you know an average offense or
slightly above average
and this team could be in the super bowl
conversation so
i'm with you i'm rooting for big ben i
always think he is underrated as a
player
on the field because of some of what his
life has been off the field people that
hold that against
him and you know to me i try to separate
them and i think he's a phenomenal
football player
all right oh well i guess
baby yeah how could i not pick tom brady
i mean yes he's under pressure
he uh he hammers it aryans i i don't
know
you're right it's a good question it is
a good question you're right because
bruce arians is under a lot of pressure
too it's that's a good one i'll take
brady since i spit that out first
but i do think you're right to add him
into that conversation maybe i should
have done that but
yeah brady hey he made a big move he
left the patriots you know he's got the
weapons around him now we're all
expecting all these big things and
i don't think any of us expect anything
bad
especially with the talent around them
so the expectations are very high for a
guy that's gone to a new team that
hasn't won in
a long long time which is kind of crazy
and i but i get it i get it there's a
lot of talent on the roster to like and
everything about it
um so i'll go with with you know tom
brady the new look bucks and then gotta
go play the new orleans saints is not
gonna be easy
yeah and bruce arians has pressure
because we've seen what tom brady can do
with bill belichick for 20 years and
plenty of the coaches out there resent
bill belichick and
you know they think the patriots cheat
because that's a better explanation than
he just kicks our asses every time
that's what it is we try to play him
right and so arians now hey look here's
apples to apples
this is the guy that that bill belichick
has taken to
six super bowl championships the
difference though is last year he wasn't
quite the same
so i don't think it's as much pressure
on bruce arians i tend to agree with you
that brady wanted this
right be careful what you wish for tommy
because now you have a new team
and let's go see what you can do against
a a division rival that really is a
rival not a cupcake that you feast on
twice a year
and case in point brady is an underdog
going into a regular season game for the
first time in a very
long time all right i am going to go
to cleveland baker mayfield yeah that's
who i was in
i was tossing it up with the last pick
yep well and
and this is very simple other than
tony dungy somehow landing
with a job that already had peyton
manning there
it's not very often that
a coaching job becomes open with a great
quarterback now mike mccarthy had it
this year with dak prescott but usually
there's an issue with the quarterback
that causes the team to be bad enough
for the coach to be fired
and with baker mayfield even though he
was great in 2018 last year he regressed
and every coach unless he has a
clear-cut franchise quarterback
at some point wants his own guy and who
does
kevin stefanski sign first order of
business and free agency he gets case
keenum
they're one year together in minnesota
it was special
they had they have as their shared
experience
the minneapolis miracle for crying out
loud that's part of their personal
history
and so if baker doesn't straighten up
and fly right as my dad always used to
tell me to do and after about 25 years
it took
then then there's an alternative it's
not quite as glaring as baker mayfield
and nick or as mitchell trubisky and
nick foles
but it's there chris and if mayfield
doesn't step up
it's something that i think by the time
we get to halloween it's some
it's something that's going to at least
be discussed and at a minimum pondered
by stefanski i i
i hear you mike i do uh it's it's a big
year for baker mayfield i i don't want
to say it's do or die or anything like
that but it certainly
is big enough to i go this could affect
his future as far as how he's looked at
or man if he plays really bad he's gonna
really have to rebuild himself and the
way he's perceived around football
yeah it was loose and bad decisions and
bad throws last year
all of it and there was issues there and
this is going to be a different approach
and not that they have to win in week
one but i think we all just want to see
can baker play
good consistent football which guy yeah
which guy
and the problem is the the 2019 baker
went to baltimore and won
right it's it's crazy and a big part of
that was nick chubb and hopefully kevin
stefanski can do that maybe
to run the ball and take the pressure
off of baker but i'm with you
uh that's a scary situation and you're
right with the keys keenum's history
there
that that would scare me if i'm baker
where if you fought there and you're two
and four
watch out because that that could be a
change that's made all right
um i think i'll have to go jimmy g here
aha yeah got it i left it for you yeah i
got to do it well
just come on there's some there's so
much talk about him all off season
whether it's getting replaced by brady
the throws he missed in the super bowl
the
yards he left out there the way the
playoffs really just unfolded in front
of us
made us kind of go back to the
requestion
conversation of jimmy garoppolo got the
cardinals we expect them
to beat the the arizona cardinals this
weekend but
i think we're all going to be looking at
it to go okay what's the guy we're going
to see this year was he affected by last
year has he gotten better
or do they still have to manage the
offense the same way as they always did
so we'll see
all right last pick for me and i was
saving this when i knew you would leave
it for me because
i love him i love him here we go i love
him not
hey is there not pressure right because
what was the narrative
last year after they beat the saints he
made the big throw to adam thielen in
the playoffs
and it's like hey kirk is different now
he's won a big game
he's fixed he's fine well guess what big
game coming the only good news is
it's not a night game and let's see if
kirk can stand up with aaron rod
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports